Ah, Thank you.
Ah, hello, everybody.
And yeah, I'd like to join
Marlee and other presenters
in think in RStudio
and film and others
into putting the
session together.
You know, this is my favorite
community are in Parma
and I'm glad to be here today.
And also Thank you
for the opportunity
to talk about our innocence
and drug discovery statistics.
So my name is walia
Putin and work
as a principal statistician
and the Department
of translational medicine
and early development
statistics at Janssen.
So what do we do it?
Johnson well, and Johnson.
We are guided by our mission
of Blandin heart, science
and ingenuity to profoundly
changed the trajectory
of health for humanity.
And we discover and develop
drugs which, you know,
treat or lead to prevent some
of the world's devastating
diseases.
So how do we discover
and develop drugs?
Well, the process
is quite complex,
but it roughly
can be broken down
into two parts preclinical
drug discovery and development
efforts and clinical, and I
think clinical drug discovery,
drug development gets
a lot of spotlight,
whether preclinical phase is
not as commonly talked about.
So I'd like to take
a couple of minutes
and to give you in a
nutshell, what that really
means to discover a drug.
Right so it all starts
with choosing which to do.
So you're off to.
Right and then
after you do that,
you identify the target that
you're going to try to pursue.
Once you have that
in place, are you
trying to screen
possible compounds
or even engineer a new one?
They're going to
bind to your target.
And once that is
done, you basically
study that relationship
or that activity
is happening between your
compounds and target.
And you might want to
optimize it and look
at it at many, many angles.
But what happens at the end?
You select a subset of
compounds that you're
going to be moving forward
into other subset of studies.
And once you have your
subset of compounds,
you would further test them
for efficacy and safety using
in vitro, which is
outside of your living
living body sort of
experiments, which
could be testing those compounds
and tissue and cell lines.
And then also in
vivo experiments
where you test your compounds
in a living organism.
And then, you know,
once that is done,
you're basically ready to move
your final compound into, you
know, enemy phase,
which is nominated
for a new molecular entity.
And that's sort of complete
your preclinical drug discovery
process.
But as you can see, it's very,
very involved and very, very,
very multifaceted.
So I work for drug discovery.
This is the group that
basically supports
all of these different
drug discovery
efforts across different
therapeutic areas,
whether it's neuroscience,
oncology, immunology,
infectious diseases, vaccines.
And we do a lot of work
working with the scientists.
So what our
department does, it's
obviously bringing mathematical
and statistical rigor
into building this
drug discovery pipeline
and also for decision making.
Right and so how do we do it?
Well, you know, we take the
body of data, a lot of studies
that biologists have conducted.
And, you know, one
of the aspects for us
is obviously designing
those studies and work
on the set of experiments.
But also they have a
task for us is to analyze
all of the data that.
Right so we put the data into
the sausage making machine,
radical statistics.
We add some magic to it and
voila, we get AP value, right?
Of course, I'm joking.
It's not as nice as
it is on the slide.
But instead of
magic, we obviously
have a lot of math
and statistics
within our sausage
making machine.
Right and p-value is
one of the things,
but it's never the only one.
And we accompany all of our
findings with, you know,
a lot of different
tables, figures,
graphical representation.
And a lot of different reports.
Right but we're trying
to go with all of this
is that, you know, we
have this process in place
for analyzing the data.
But what's really great
is that this whole process
is driven by our right in
drug discovery statistics
department at Johnson.
We heavily rely in
RStudio products.
And this is what my
presentation is about.
So how do we use
our capabilities
and what do we do with our
drug discovery statistics?
Well, the most important one
is our portfolio support.
So we use our extensively to
analyze a lot of our studies.
So when I was
thinking how to best.
Kind of pr.
what do we do with our father
about pluton, all the stuff
that we do into this
for different spheres?
Right so first and foremost is
our general practices, right.
The majority of us use
RStudio and we do it.
We use it locally and we
also use it off the server.
And the server.
Our RStudio capabilities
are great because what
they help us to do
is share our project
and our different study
analysis between ourselves
within the group and help us
to collaborate in this manner.
But also we've
been tappet lately
in the powerful computing
capabilities of RStudio Server
as well for our analysis, but
also for Shiny app development.
We all use it in Bitbucket.
So Bitbucket is our
local github, we call it,
which of course ensures
traceability and transparency
of everything that
we do, but also plays
a big role in collaboration
and code sharing.
We extensively
used our packages,
so we create our own, whether
they're internal and external
for, of course,
organizing our own code,
but also for sharing our
methodologies with others,
which, of course, speaks
to the rigor and innovation
that R packages bring to the
whole drug discovery statistics
base.
We also start packaging our
standardized analysis workflow
that we actually use to create
shinya apps into packages as
well.
And that's, again, an easy way
to share your code, but also
makes it easy to
troubleshoot or to bring
changes that might
need to be implemented
if the opportunity comes.
We also use R packages
for packaging,
basically templates
for our markdown, which
I'm going to discuss next.
Our Markdown report,
something that we simply
can't survive these
days, so we extensively
use R Markdown reports
for a lot of stuff,
I think in 2018 or maybe
at the end of that year,
there was a big
effort in a department
to create one standardized
parametrized, R Markdown
template, which kind
of incorporates the set
expectation between ourselves,
statistician of how we want
to report our
statistics, but also
between our clients,
our biologists
and whoever we work with.
So what happens last
year is we decided
to make that parameterized
general template more
specific to therapeutic
area that we work with.
For instance, I mainly
support oncology,
so we really customize that
template that we created first
into oncology settings, which is
really cool because, you know,
we can customize it
whenever we want it.
But it also brings consistency
to all the analysis
that we do within oncology
drug discovery space.
And obviously a
speaks to reproducible
nature of our research, my
favorite and everybody's
favorite, our shiny EPS.
We do a lot of them.
We put them together
ourselves and some of them
are worth for some of them are
we have our developers helping
us as well.
When I was thinking how
to present the China,
it just we have you know,
we can talk about them.
The whole day.
But I basically put
everything that we do
in terms of our Shiny into $3.
So the first set of
applications that we developed
for drug discovery kind
of goes into the bucket
of data manipulation.
So that could be
anything from, you know,
taking different data
files that scientists
have coming from different
software that they're using
and putting them into shiny
and, you know, mapping the data,
merging the files, doing
some other pre processing.
And then basically
exploiting some other data
file type that they
need the scientists need
to put into another software
or something like that.
Right so it could be
an array of things
that we can do with
data, which is great,
that we can use Shiny for that
because it really eliminates
any copy paste or editing
error and gives us.
So much confidence
that nothing like that
has happened while
we're preprocessing
manipulating our data.
So once we have the data
in the right form shape,
the next thing that
we do in statistics
is obviously take a closer look
at the data and we call it.
So another set of
shinee applications
that we have developed
kind of go into that market
where they have to do
with data visualization
and exploration of your data,
which is super important.
And brain efficiency
in that space kind
of talks to having the
more thorough research
and obviously, you know, a
richer body of evidence when
it comes to data exploration.
And then the last
bucket is basically
apps that have to do with
statistical analysis.
Right and here with develop
standardized workflows
for a particular
analysis that scientists
are doing repeatedly.
A lot of those app have
exportable Markdown report.
What is PDF in a Word
or email, you name it.
And this brings
major efficiencies
in our space because
of automation
of those repetitive tasks
and analysis and reporting
generation.
And of course, because
of RStudio capabilities,
we can easily deploy
the apps and share them
with our colleagues in biology.
So, you know, four of these
things, general practices
are shiny abs and R
packages and R Markdown
report help us tremendously in
a portfolio development space.
But what else we're
doing with our.
Well, I have the second part
where which are innovation.
Right so what do I mean by that?
Well, obviously,
this speaks a lot
to open source nature of
our that we all benefit from
and sharing, which
really facilitates
not just within
department collaborations.
Right but collaboration across
function across companies
with John Johnson
and even beyond going
into the community.
So analysis
automation that we're
doing with shiny apps and
R Markdown reports really
allow us to release
a lot of resources.
So we can go and explore other
cutting edge technologies
and bringing
innovative solutions
to our drug discovery space.
Now, immediate access to all
the R packages, whether we're
creating our own or
using someone else's,
facilitates innovative
drug discovery,
statistical solutions that
we create in our department.
And then something new
that Johnson Johnson
haven't had before.
And had it into 2020
is jeng hackathon
that really bringing together
a lot of different employees
from different parts of
Johnson Johnson, whether you're
in consumer or medical
devices or pharma,
to work on solving some of
the very interesting business
problems.
You know, and I'm proud to
say that whoever participated
in that, those hackathon from
discovery, discovery, drug
discovery statistics
are all using R
to solve those problems.
So papoulias support
innovation, what else?
Right, training.
We've conducted a lot of
smaller trainings that
have to do with our.
But I want to concentrate
on to bigger ones.
So the first one in
graphics with our
which have been talked
about in previous years
at the conferences that are in
pharma and maybe others, where
statistics and decision
science department at Johnson
put it together and look at
it with the aim of improving
literacy in our programming.
I'm clinical
statistician, so it was
conducted to more than hundreds
clinical statisticians that
went into the training.
And it was presented by external
our experts and a lot of them
came from drug
discovery statistics
group, which I belong to.
So what we've done were created
a lot of different homeworks
on different topics
that cover gedo
plot was start the usual plot.
And there was a major intention,
but the appetite just grew
and we had to expand to R
Markdown interactive blood
skydiver's dashboards.
And I think we ended up with
a small shinee app at the end.
But we would deliver homework
for four people, for trainees,
and then they would go in to
review and regroup, session
and brainstorm solutions.
And then they would present the
solution on the general forum
and discuss that.
And then the expert
would sort of
come with their tips and
tricks presentations.
So it worked really well.
And it was in 2019.
Janssen so what
happened last year?
And another great training
was designed and delivered
and that was led by quantitative
sciences organization.
And the aim there was
to promote a shared
foundation of quantitative
literacy in machine learning
space.
I was a major, major effort.
That was 25 week course, again,
presented by internal experts.
Those are statistician who
have advanced degree in machine
learning, including, again, a
colleague of mine and myself.
And they're mostly
pretty obviously,
who presented content,
machine learning that
was structured in
four different modules
about statistical learning
and classification.
You supervised,
unsupervised approaches
and was attended by
hundreds of people
from all over the company.
So that's going outside of Jan.
Anyone in the way we had
it going was, you know,
discussion of the
theoretical part.
And then practical
data application.
And again, I'm proud to say
that for the practical data
application part,
we use our entirely
and we use aren't Markdown
down for all of our code.
We had a standardized
template, the well used,
and we're basically deliberate
all the solution in R Markdown.
And that sort of goes
in the repositories
that a lot of changes
or people who attended
or who didn't attend.
But want to learn.
Can tap into.
Now So we talked about papoulias
support, innovation, training,
but I think are also helps
to be to build communities,
whether it's for our driven.
So something that
we have going on.
And this is the
stuff that, you know,
I'm kind of involved in
participating in organizing,
but maybe there are
more is something
is something like a new day that
we've been having for, I think,
three years, which is an
annual event that is organized
by Johnson quantitative sciences
and scientific computation,
a company computing
operations in partnership
with the data and
statistics society,
which I co-lead with some other
people where we're basically
bringing our shiny
developers together,
not one or two day event.
And, you know, back
in prequalified time,
we would actually need on
site, on different sides
to get each other and share
some exciting work that we're
doing in shiny application
development space.
But last year, we had
it obviously remote.
So that has been of a great
interest in the community.
There is growing also within
Jasjeet data and statistics
society.
We do have workshops where we
talk about, Ah, or, you know,
discuss some of the methods
developed in you know,
the example, there could
be what, even having topics
like using different software.
But how do we plug-in
those softwares.
And we had something
about Tableau going on
and you know, how to
bring our capabilities
or how to Connect with
Tableau and stuff like that.
So we also have,
yagmur, internal groups
where our community is
bubbling and growing
and I'm really happy to be
part of it and see it grow.
And I think a
separate community,
something that we have
around internal Bitbucket
or, you know,
internal GitHub where
people share code and sort
of create collaborations.
Something else that we all
love is hecks sticker's.
So I love those like everybody
else in this community.
And I try to bring them in any
effort that I'm involved with.
So some of the stickers
that we've developed
are kind of go for our
shiny app that we created.
And I see an example
of the World app
that I put together and
have a sticker for it.
And then we put
stickers together
for different workshops
or events that we have.
You see a shiny sticker and
then some of the workshop
that we had within that.
And also we have a
sticker for a membership,
for the statistics aside, which
were actually in quite demand
that we had to email them
globally, which which is great.
So, to summarize, are enhancing
drug discovery statistics
today and tomorrow.
So I think today we have to
rely on RStudio products we
use RStudio products R
Markdown reports, shiny abs,
our packages, which
bring efficiencies
and statistical rigor
to our portfolio.
They ensure reproducible and
traceable research and also
standardization and
harmonization of methods,
workflows, et cetera and
give us the capability
to quickly adapt to changes.
Then open source nature
of our provides us
with immediate access
and opportunity
to share our kidon
edge and state of the R
statistical methodologies and
also facilitates innovation
and collaboration.
And then we're growing
our community internally
through different platforms,
workshops, internal events
and trainings.
And we're trying to give
back to the community
by having our packages,
songkran and presenting
at different conferences.
Some notes for future potential.
I think we can keep
building a larger community
and not just within our
Janssen Pharmaceuticals phase,
but also going to other
Johnson Johnson sectors,
whether it's medical devices
or consumer finance, et cetera.
So that's always a
great thing to do.
I think there are ways to
work on sharing our code again
across the enterprise, not
just within subcommunities.
So I think that
would be something
great to do in the future.
And then enhance an internal
R packages visibility.
This is something I
also feel is important.
And we can work better there.
And with that, I'm
going to conclude
and say Thank you to
some of my colleagues
who helped me to bounce
back some of my ideas
that I had for
this presentation.
And once again,
Thank you to RStudio.
And people who organized
this are in pharma conference
for inviting me to speak.
And here.
I'll conclude.
Thank you so much.